[Music]
right now let's start with somebody who
is poised to be the next Oprah reese
witherspoon I was with her last night at
the launch of her new Direct TV series
Reese is doing it all and she's even
making time to bring back everybody's
favorite feminist elwood I have to tell
you we are beyond excited about Legally
Blonde coming back
how thrills are you to be stepping back
into those iconic stilettos
hi I'm Elwood oh it's gonna be so fun I
got to go to a meeting the other day
where we talked about all the new plot
points and all the characters and some
returning characters and some new
characters and it's I mean I got so
excited just in the meeting I was like
this is gonna be good okay so we're in
for some good stuff
what is Elle Woods up to this time I
can't tell you but Reese did open up
about season two of big little lies and
this epic moment throwing ice cream at
Meryl Streep yes I did that it's
probably a it's a top five moment in my
career for sure but I can't remember the
other fork Reese reenacted the toss last
night on the red carpet for her new
Direct TV project her own take on a talk
show shine on with Reese a lot of people
say you're the next Oprah what advice
has she given you oh my god first of all
there's only one Oprah and I should be
so lucky to even walk in a path that she
cut for any of us how much fun has this
been for you when you got to sit down
and chat with people like Dolly Parton
with pink wow that's incredible okay
real talk Dolly Parton was really
terrified I'm so scared
she's been an idol of mine forever which
one do you want to wear oh my god Reese
is building a media empire and she's
also a mother of three
hard to believe daughter Ava is 18 Ava
going to college how tough will it be
for you why are you trying to make me
cry
and I was inside after the red carpet
and I saw Ava and the whole family there
supporting Reese they were incredibly
proud as they should be with this new
project it's crazy that she's already
ready for college
[Music]